Newtonian determinism says that the
universe is a clock a gigantic clock
that's wound up at the beginning of time
and it's been ticking ever since
according to Newton's laws of motion so
what you're gonna eat ten years from now
on January 1st has already been fixed
it's already known using newton's laws
of motion
Einstein believed in that Einstein was a
determinist well does that mean that a
murderer
this horrible mass murderer isn't really
guilty of his works because it was
already preordained billions of years
ago nine sign said well yeah in some
sense that's true even mass murderers
were predetermined but he said they
should still be placed in jail
Heisenberg then comes along and proposes
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle and
says nonsense there's uncertainty you
don't know where the electron is it
could be here here or many places
simultaneously
this of course I'm Stein hated because
he said God doesn't play dice with the
universe
well hey get used to it
Einstein was wrong God does play dice
every time we look an electron it moves
there's uncertainty with regards to the
position of the electron so what does
that mean for free will it means in some
sense we do have some kind of free will
no one can determine your future events
given your past history there's always
the wild card
there's always the possibility of
uncertainty in whatever we do so when I
look at myself in a mirror I say to
myself what I'm looking at is not really
me it looks like me but it's not really
me at all
it's not me today now it's me a
billionth of a second ago because it
takes a billionth of a second for light
to go from me to the mirror and back